according to the u.n 1.7 million
ukrainians are now refugees millions
more are desperately attempting to leave
the country and for good reason uh view
a warning here what you're about to see
is extremely graphic and it is extremely
disturbing and these are the sights and
the sounds of vladimir putin's war and
the targeting of men women and children
because at the direction of this thug
dictator russia has begun now shelling
residential neighborhoods homes
apartment buildings leveling entire
towns the human toll is
almost impossible to count at this time
and it's very hard to watch at times
russia will agree to a ceasefire in
order to allow civilians quote safe
passage out of the war zone and then
he's targeting those very same civilians
moments later with indiscriminate
bombing attacks now this is an image of
an entire family including two children
apparently murdered in one such attack
this is a picture from the first lady of
ukraine showing a father desperately
rushing his 18 month old baby to a
hospital after a shelling barrage that
little boy is now reportedly dead and
look at your screen we are witnessing a
mass casualty situation before our very
eyes and for what to fulfill the selfish
territorial dreams of an evil
murdery maniacal megalomaniac dictator
does anyone around putin in his inner
circle generals advisers do you actually
believe this is a good thing or you're
just following orders and making that
your lame excuse as i've said before
there's one way to stop this war and if
anyone around putin has a backbone a
soul a conscience
guess what they need to do get him out
of power by any means necessary and i
say that unapologetically for you
liberal critics out there how many more
children do you need to see dead before
you get to that position meanwhile putin
has reportedly even sent death squads
into ukraine uh to assassinate president
zielinski and his family so as far as
i'm concerned what goes around will come
around and vladimir putin should watch
his back and by the way why are we still
importing russian oil america needs to
pause here
because vladimir putin is literally
selling energy to our country every nato
ally country especially germany and
western european countries and he's
making billions of dollars every single
day
uh and in this country we were energy
independent joe biden inherited energy
independence we were net exporter of
energy when he became president
in fact he gave that up also we have a
100 year supply of oil and gas at a
minimum
right here in the u.s some people say up
to 200 years but instead of tapping
these you know real natural resources
abundance that we have the biden
administration is now begging other
countries that don't like us to produce
more oil to ease the pain at the pump
when we could be going into business
with texas in oklahoma and alaska and
over the weekend u.s officials they
actually traveled to venezuela to work
out a deal with vile dictator nicholas
maduro there and meanwhile as we speak
diplomats are attempting to open up uh
america to more iranian oil shipments
that's right the muellers of the
iran that say death to israel death to
america as part of this madness insane
uh brokered nuclear deal that they're
trying to do and by the way a deal
brokered by russia you can't make this
up in a spy novel this is by definition
insanity it is weakness on a level that
i've never seen in this country before
and it is extraordinarily dangerous that
we want to partner with the countries
that hate us the most when we have the
natural resources right here in this
country to not only take care of our
needs but the needs of our allies in
europe and tonight there's also
speculation that biden may soon make a
presidential trip to saudi arabia to beg
them to increase their oil production uh
in what world does any of this make any
sense we have enough oil and gas to
supply the us and our allies for a
hundred years so to all you climate cult
alarmists in the democratic party i have
a question that no one's been able to
answer tell me what the difference is if
you get a
how does it impact mother earth
differently if you drill for oil in the
united states or venezuela or iran or
opec countries or russia or here
if anything it is more environmentally
responsible actually to drill right here
at home but get this the biden as biden
begs the world to produce more gas and
oil and energy prices are shooting
through the roof and there's another
solution according to a small town mayor
turned biden's transportation secretary
and according to good old mayor pete
with his vast array of experience
americans still struggling to fill up
their gas tanks just need to go to a
dealership and shell out sixty thousand
dollars for an electric vehicle i'm sure
they can afford that too take a look
clean transportation can bring
significant cost savings for the
american people as well
last month we announced a 5 billion
investment to build out a nationwide
electric vehicle charging network so the
people from rural to suburban to urban
communities can all benefit from the gas
savings of driving an ev
this is the same guy nonchalantly said
after the keystone xl pipeline workers
were fired oh we want you to just go get
another high-paying union job well they
actually had skill specific
uh issues that
that are not applicable elsewhere oh
find another job oh okay another
high-paying job
great advice mayor pete now today vice
president harris genius that she is said
it's time to transition to green energy
is that why they refuse to drill here
drill now so americans can save money uh
can you be that can you be any more out
of touch than that elon musk by the way
brilliant genius here he is uh in his
own right somebody i think is very
interesting and an incredible
entrepreneur founder ceo of the electric
vehicle giant known as tesla he's
calling for more domestic energy
production and by the way against his
own interest because he says
extraordinary times need extraordinary
measures look at this rasmussen poll 70
percent of americans agree but the biden
administration is just too afraid of the
radical socialist climate alarmist cult
that is the new green deal socialist
party and instead of standing up to
these radicals the administration would
rather you the american people pay more
for everything rather he could stand up
to his own party and say these are
extraordinary times we need to once
again be energy independent he has that
option he refuses to even talk about
that option instead we have a 40-year
high of inflation all the food you buy
all the gas you put in your car all the
money you spend to heat and cool your
home everything you buy in every store
costs more because joe cares more about
his new green deal socialist party than
he does about the american people they'd
also rather import oil from russia
venezuela iran
and opec and beg and plead and get on
your knees rather than being energy
independent here being our best national
security interests as well
just so the u.s can transition away
their words from domestic fossil fuel
production now tonight we should be
negotiating with the governor of texas
the governor of oklahoma the governor of
alaska as a matter of fact
we don't need to negotiate all we need
to do is say go
produce as much energy as you possibly
can and we shouldn't be talking to
dictators on other continents we should
restart the keystone xl pipeline we
should open up those auctions once again
exploration on anwar once again we
should end the ban on exploration and
federal lands and simply do whatever it
takes to dramatically ramp up our
production of oil natural gas and
liquefied natural gas but does biden do
any of that no so when joe says he's
willing to do anything and everything to
bring down the prices of you know a
gallon of gasoline just know he's lying
straight to your face now take a look at
this exchange between our own peter
ducey and jenn saki from earlier today
would president biden ever undo his
executive order that stopped the
construction of the keystone xl pipeline
are you suggesting that would solve the
gas prices issue well do you think that
that would maybe affect prices faster
than getting the whole country off of
fossil fuels i actually don't think it
would the keystone
was not an oil field it's a pipeline
also the oil is continuing to flow in
just through other means
so it actually would have nothing to do
with the current supply imbalance hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else